it's become an end of the day ritual
outside west kowloon magistrates court
a crowd chance defiant slogans as prison
vans take away those convicted
or on trial over last year's unrest but
the throng was bigger on wednesday
so it wasn't possible to see which of
the vehicles
contained the three high-profile
activists among the more than two
thousand people
prosecuted since last june joshua wong
agnes chao and ivan lamb avoided a
heavier sentence
after pleading guilty last week the
trio's detractors
celebrated with champagne in spite of
titan covert 19 restrictions
banning public gatherings of more than
two people for the activists supporters
though
it was another blow and this is
destroyed our rule of law
and we are very we are very disappointed
but we will add oil we oil
they are not righteous none of the hong
kong resources the government now
wong is no stranger to prison he's
already served three jail terms
the activists were convicted of offences
that took place last june
when protesters laid siege to the police
headquarters
marking the start of months of unrest
agnes
chao who turns 24 on thursday burst into
tears
as the sentence was read out joshua wong
was in characteristically
defiant mood shouting tough days are
ahead
but we will hang in there chao is due to
return to court next year
she was arrested in august under a harsh
new national security law
on suspicion of colluding with foreign
powers
but has yet to be charged nick silam is
a former local politician
and a supporter of that law there are a
lot of people
some activists such as joshua wong and
next child was
actively um trying to promote in
hong kong independence and that is the
fact i know some of them were
trying to say well we didn't ask for it
but
look at the look at the fact and look at
the evidence hong kong's leader carrie
lam
says she's restored order after last
year's unrest
part of that process the almost weekly
prosecutions
of young protesters including now its
best known ones
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong